Carrefour will freeze prices on 100 everyday products.
That's according to the French supermarket on Monday.
The company said items from tin sardines...
...to rice and washing-up liquid would have prices frozen.
It comes following pressure...
...from President Emmanuel Macron's government for business...
...to help tackle inflation.
French oil major TotalEnergies and shipping giant CMA CGM...
...also took steps in July to cut prices,...
...that as they faced a super tax on record profits.
Earlier this year, French supermarket group Leclerc...
...froze prices on the 120 most bought products through to July.
Carrefour said it would freeze prices until November 30th.
Data show this month that French inflation rose 6.8 percent in July...
...that was lower than most other EU countries...
...due to government caps on power and gas prices.